the structure of the phenomenology is
not purely linear
right when we go through the
Consciousness section for example
we do so at the start and we do so in
great detail right and there's all sorts
of surprises along the way that's part
of the dialectical process we start out
with oh I think this is the way it is we
finally reached our stable finish point
and now we understand things and then
Hegel says what let me pull the rug out
from underneath and things get more
complicated multiple points in the work
we've got the previously
traversed dug through section
and it does get sublated brought into at
a higher level both of abstraction and
of context and meaning other sections